[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa tarde
chegamos aqui
brincadeira à parte tudo foi planejado
porque hoje quero justamente falar sobre
isso
como funciona nossa mente mediante
aquilo que nós observamos provavelmente
vocês pensaram de imediato um
palestrante do ted tal que nervoso isso
não vai dar certo
isso vai dar errado a nossa mente
funciona assim com aquilo que nós
observamos e associações com aquilo que
nós já conhecemos então quero te
convidar esses próximos minutos
a sonhar a pensar deixar a sua
imaginação flui
quem de nós nunca desejou ser semelhante
ao personagem principal de um filme
marcante talvez os mais velhos desejaram
ser um ramo em algum momento da vida
um jogador de futebol talvez os mais
jovens ea desejaram ser semelhante a um
super herói da atualidade
a incrível como aquilo que nos envolve
aquilo que nós comemos aquilo que nós
bebemos tem a capacidade de moldar de
transformar a nossa imaginação e os
nossos sonhos nossos desejos
eu me lembro muito bem que no ano de
eu assisti creio que muitos aqui também
um filme a que marcou época de volta
para o futuro
vocês lembram desse filme é um filme
futurístico a que existia um jovem
ousado e destemido que tinha como amigo
professor um tanto quanto malucão e
naquele filme foram lançadas algumas
possíveis tecnologias de um futuro
distante que moldaria um futuro distante
futuro que é este que hoje que nós
estamos vivendo
eram carros voadores roupas auto
ajustáveis viagem no tempo eu me lembro
muito bem naquela segunda-feira à noite
uma daquelas inovações algo que apareceu
aquele filme foi um gatilho que mudou a
minha história foi observar a utilização
de lixo resíduos
isso mesmo caso
de frutas como combustível daquele
supercarro chamado de lori 1
vocês devem lembrar disso e eu fiquei
pensando será que no futuro isso será
uma realidade será possível produzir
combustível a partir de um lixo a partir
de um resíduo
existe um ditado popular que diz que
sonhar não custa nada é verdade não
custa nada e ainda pode render muito
a célebre albert einstein certa vez
disse que a imaginação é mais importante
do que a ciência uma vez que a ciência
ela possui limites é verdade mas a
imaginação ela abrange o mundo inteiro o
que eu estou tentando dizer pra vocês
agora é que aquilo que nos circunda
aquilo que nos envolve tem a capacidade
tem o poder de fecundar a nossa
imaginação
por isso que nós precisamos que os
processos pedagógicos vigentes nas
instituições de ensino que as mídias de
massa que as mídias de rede que as
relações sociais que as relações
familiares que elas possibilitem que
elas afirmem novas diversas atividades
imagina a dor as tudo aquilo que nos
envolve serve para moldar a nossa
imaginação
só que gostaria de passar dois gatilhos
que são importantes para você aproveitar
o meio e desenvolver novas tecnologias
primeiro gatilho
nós precisamos de ambientes e situações
que impulsione um ambiente de pressão
muitas vezes as nossas salas de aula nas
universidades em escolas mais ambiente
de relaxamento não de medo porque um
medo de errar ele estrelas da nossa
capacidade criativa
pra mim o gatilho inicial ambiente de
funcionamento foi assistindo um vídeo um
filme e pra você o que impulsiona o seu
poder criativo isaac newton estava
debaixo de uma árvore e curtindo a
natureza e de repente um fruto tais
sobre ele
esse foi o gatilho ea partir daí se
inicia teoria da gravidade
arquimedes estava na sua banheira
relaxando observou a vazão de líquidos
esse foi o gatilho ea partir daí
desenvolveu a teoria de fluidos jorge
demonstrar ao passeando nos alpes com
seu cachorro e de repente ele observa
que sementes com alguns ganchos
estruturas aderiram muito bem as suas
roupas ea partir daí ele desenvolve o
velcro persa spence estava curtindo uma
barra de chocolate derreter no seu bolso
ea partir disso aí
desenvolve um microondas que eu e muitos
de nós temos as nossas casas
esse gatilho importante ambientes que
impulsione a nossa capacidade criadora
um segundo gatilho são as perguntas
perguntem questionem indaguem sempre a
essência
muitas vezes as perguntas são mais
importantes do que as respostas
eu sei que é difícil fazemos perguntas
de algo que nós nunca vimos o imaginamos
principalmente porque a simples neural
de processo que nós nunca vimos depende
de estímulo que nós recebemos na fase de
infância e justamente por ser difícil
fazemos perguntas corretas
grande parte tem uma tendência a pensar
sempre na mesma casinha dentro da mesma
caixinha o tempo passa as instituições
nós acabamos ficando chovendo no molhado
mas nós não precisamos ficar dessa forma
esses dois gatilhos estão disponíveis e
precisamos aprender e utilizar sabe
porque não existem mentes impenetráveis
existem chaves erradas
todos nós o ser humano faz parte de
deles poder criativo em natal nós é algo
de muito especial que todos nós temos
nós recebemos precisamos identificá-lo
desenvolver e utilizar a transformação
do nosso próximo daquele que está ao
nosso redor
quero te convidar então para seguir o
raciocínio e mostrar de forma prática
por onde caminha ei o que desenvolvi o
que queria e como você também pode criar
então pense comigo vamos sonhar vamos
imaginar algo talvez muito estranho para
muitos
imagine se fosse
possível produzimos um combustível só
que durante a produção desse combustível
nós não utilizasse nenhum tipo de
defensivo agrícola ou baixíssima
quantidade ser incrível para nossa saúde
para a saúde humana nas nascentes na
questão da sustentabilidade
isso é possível nós vamos continuar
imaginando se fosse possível produzir um
combustível
só que não fosse necessário desmatar mos
nenhum paulo ou mais sem ser necessário
plantar um palmo de qualquer monocultura
agressiva
isso é realidade e se possível quero te
convidar a pensar mas eu quero pensar
mais um pouco imagine que esse
combustível ele não depende de uma
estação do ano ele pode ter uma produção
constante independente de fatores
climáticos
uau é ver isso seria inovador isso
transformaria na sociedade
mas calma continue a pensar continua
imaginar se fosse possível que esse
combustível além de tudo nós já
apresentamos ele não fosse de origem
fóssil mas sim de uma origem renovável
que tivesse uma pegada verde
de acordo com tudo que nós desejamos uma
sociedade no futuro
imagine que esse combustível fosse
originado da segunda biomassa mais
abundante do planeta perdendo apenas
para a celulose
se existe esse é possível imaginar ainda
mais
vamos sonhar eu gosto de sonhar como
criança que esses que esse combustível
ele é originado de uma biomassa tem sido
descartada toneladas e toneladas
diariamente nos oceanos em aterros em
diversas partes do mundo
ou seja a utilização de um resíduo para
benefício imagine que esse processo
estivesse acessível a pequenos e grandes
produtores uma vez que assim diz esse
combustível é de baixo custo e o melhor
pra mim
imagine que esse combustível com todas
as características ainda permite a
inserção de vulneráveis permitisse a
inserção daqueles que são descartados da
sociedade catadores que agora podem
utilizar um resíduo
e assim transformar suas famílias suas
cidades
incrível né pensar que essa tecnologia
ela está disponível para nós mas mais do
que sonhar mais do que planejar é
concretizar é realizar hoje isso é uma
realidade
eu juntamente com dois professores
doutores professor adão professor sérgio
uma parceria do instituto federal do
tocantins e da universidade federal do
tocantins
nós pegamos um composto que existe na
casca dos crustáceos camarão lagosta
siri resíduos lixo e produzimos um
açúcar a partir de uma reação química e
nesta
isso mesmo você está observando o
primeiro açúcar de origem animal do
planeta
talvez você pense igual isso é tudo isso
não é tudo
porque como einstein disse a nossa
imaginação ela não tem limites
então gostaria de apresentar algumas
novidades a mais sobre esse açúcar
ele não obtido unicamente da carapaça
dos crustáceos
nós conseguimos produzir esse açúcar
também a parte da parede celular dos
fundos
um grupo de seres vivos extremamente
abundante nosso planeta e mais nós
podemos produzir esse açúcar a partir do
da carapaça de insetos ou seja o maior
grupo de animais o nosso planeta eu falo
de formigas e baratas besouros
gafanhotos
tudo isso está disponível para nós
hoje essa é uma tecnologia real só que
tem mais só que tem mais o que nós
podemos fazer com esse açúcar
quais são suas aplicações possíveis
são diversas nós podemos transformar
esse açúcar em etanol em países
populosos que demandam de uma grande
quantidade de energia
uma grande quantidade de combustíveis
eles podem utilizar principalmente
aqueles países que não possuem área para
plantio não possui um clima favorável
não possui relevam eu falo de japão país
do sudeste asiático china
é isso mesmo você falar que um
combustível com tais características
ele é um ativo financeiro que poderá ser
negociado nas bolsas de valores
através do crédito de descarbonização o
biocombustíveis
mas isso não é tudo esse açúcar também
ele pode ser transformado e utilizado na
indústria de bebidas e alimentos
já imaginou cerveja a partir da casca de
camarão ou a partir da casca de baratas
eu sei não sou muito bem mas é possível
hoje a tecnologia é real imaginar pudins
rapaduras licores e cachaça originado a
partir de fios de baratas insetos
incrível poder mas na que essa
tecnologia está disponível mas tem mais
tem mais esse açúcar também ele pode ser
utilizado na indústria química e
farmacêutica solventes a partir da casca
de camarão amaciantes nylon pet já mas
não produzimos um pet a partir de fundos
a partir da casca de insetos
essa tecnologia ela está disponível
plataformas químicas ácidos hmf
indústrias de química fina
utilizando um lixo tudo isso utilizando
resíduos toneladas e toneladas sendo
descartadas diariamente as
circunstâncias que nos movem que nos
moldam dom
elas nos transformam e uma ideia boa ela
só é uma ideia boa se ela puder ser
aplicada se ela puder ser praticada uma
ideia boa é simplesmente uma ideia que
gera produtos ou coisas mas eu tenho
aprendido que uma ideia boa é
principalmente aquela ideia que gera
transformação na vida das pessoas
como tudo que nos envolve então nos
transforma nos mexe com a nossa
imaginação e nossa criatividade
meu desejo eu espero que essas poucas
palavras
o desejo que esse dia na vida de vocês
o desejo que esse ted talk silva para
modelar para moldar a pessoa geniosa que
existe dentro de você porque tudo se
aproveita da imaginação a um resíduo
tudo se aproveita para transformação do
mundo que nós tanto desejamos e
precisamos muito obrigado
[Aplausos]